the question today is should you eat
carrots on keto well what is the
glycemic index of carrots basically it's
72 it's high now what is the glycemic
index it is a scale of carbohydrates and
how fast that carbohydrate will raise
your blood sugar so below 255 is low
above 70 is high carrots
72 it's pretty high however we have to
look at the whole picture here because
there's something else called the
glycemic load which is the amount of
carbohydrates in a food and the glycemic
load will increase on more quantity but
it also takes in consideration the fiber
as well because if we have a lot of
fiber and low carbohydrate it's going to
definitely influenced this glycemic
index so the calculation is this oh I
see make index times the amount of carbs
divided by a hundred less than 10 would
be low over 21 would be high so if we
take 72 which is the glycemic index
times 4 grams of carbs for a
medium-sized carrot divided by a hundred
equals two point eight eight which is
very very very low I mean it would take
a lot of carrots to create any real
impact why is that because carrots even
know it's high in the glycemic index has
a tremendous amount of fiber so that is
gonna buffer or inhibit this glycemic
reaction however if you took the carrot
juice out of the carrot fiber that would
be very very high on the glycemic index
because we're dealing with just pure
sugar because that's gonna create a huge
spike in the glycemic response and also
there's other variables like cooking the
carrots and that can also raise the
glycemic index as well however if you're
doing raw carrots and you're not going
crazy with too many it's gonna be
totally fine on keto you don't have to
worry about it alright thanks for
watching
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications